[Music]
dear bill I don't know why you give pain
or such abuse so much abuse because of
the job that they've done because of the
amount of [ __ ] windows that have been
painted shut door knobs painted
completely over [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
latch meets the lock completely [ __ ]
painted over splotches of paint on
hardwood floors paint on the [ __ ]
windows
that's why Jesus Christ it's like did
you paint or did you [ __ ] bust a nut
it's all over the place I don't know why
you give painters so much abuse just
because you let some [ __ ] into your
house and pay them to cover your wall
with paint doesn't make them a pain or
any more than you are a barber when you
shave the red off the sides go the man
made a good point there the reason you
hire a painter is so you don't get
[ __ ] splashes of paint on your
precious Netflix money oh you know what
this whole [ __ ] thing will you [ __ ]
on [ __ ] you you [ __ ] [ __ ] I used to
wash windows you nan funny douche go to
an open mic and beat out ten million
[ __ ] comics [ __ ] you I earned every
[ __ ] cent of my Netflix money you
window paint and [ __ ] hack go [ __ ]
yourself and [ __ ] all you people who
[ __ ] on people that make it in show
business you just [ __ ] you're not
happy with your own [ __ ] lives
jesus [ __ ] christ who the [ __ ] it
ain't hurting slept on a futon until I
was 36 years old my precious netflix
money [ __ ] you I hope you step in a
bucket of paint today you [ __ ]
all right everything else was fine I
don't mind you saying that I'm not a
painter
I might call me a bald-headed [ __ ] but
you [ __ ] stay out of my pockets I
earned every [ __ ] dime I've made in
this [ __ ] business standing on stage
is a [ __ ] nobody in front of a bunch
of drunk
heckling me the whole [ __ ] way and I
took the pain and you know what my ship
came in and go [ __ ] yourself go [ __ ]
yourself I have Netflix money I'm not
giving you a drop of it I hope a bat
comes up and bite you right on your
paint select [ __ ] neck you [ __ ] all
right precious Netflix money but
designer furniture and wine he spelled
sit whi any on the sorry and whine about
it on the internet I saw you were right
there it doesn't take a genius to figure
out that there's people out there
calling themselves painters and they do
it just just as bad a job as you would
do if you do it no this is what amazes
me sir is every apartment everything
I've ever [ __ ] been in the windows
have painted shut all these all this
great old hardware every place I've
lived in has been old as [ __ ] and people
just painted over all of it and there's
paint all over the [ __ ] floor I'm
just saying look just where are these
[ __ ] great painters all right in
defense of you though if I walk into a
really nice governmental building
there's not [ __ ] paint all over the
[ __ ] floor I don't know I'm just
saying that there's a lot bit listen
listen there's a lot of bad painters out
there I would actually say there's more
bad painters out there than there's bad
comedians okay because being a bad
comedian you at least have to have a set
of balls to get on stage alright anybody
can put on their white on white Jam jams
and go walk in and start coloring on the
walls like you sir [ __ ] you the gloves
are off buddy you went after my few you
[ __ ] went after the money iron
designer furniture what does that look
like does it have the Jordache jeans on
the back stupid [ __ ] let me tell you
something about designer furniture you
can take that [ __ ] turn it up sideways
as the rock says and shove it straight
up you [ __ ] candy ass I hate all that
designer [ __ ]
I hate designer I don't like designer
clothes I bought a couple of expensive
suits when I had to [ __ ] do Letterman
and all that the biggest nightmare
ever
ever was wearing expensive clothes ever
anything you brush up against Oh
living in New York City getting in
filthy [ __ ] cabs stupid why somebody
would buy a designer couch why would you
do that so you can [ __ ] lay there and
fall asleep and drool on it I don't
understand any of that all right sir so
I know you think that I'm just sitting
here rolling around in a pile of [ __ ]
money you know with like I don't know
what my name engraved with an oil
painting of myself like I'm in [ __ ]
MTV Cribs I'm not I'm not okay so go
[ __ ] yourself
okay and I know that your little butt
hurt here okay why don't you take the
paintbrush out of your [ __ ] ass you
baby and you know take a little
criticism anyways all right it doesn't
take a genius actually agree with a lot
of his points either what it really is
is shut the [ __ ] up about the fact that
I actually took a chance and my dream
came true
go [ __ ] yourself and [ __ ] all you
[ __ ] people who keep [ __ ] on
celebrities and their big-ass [ __ ]
kitchens they earned them all right do
you have the balls to stand across the
table from a naked Harvey Weinstein
that's in heat do you want to [ __ ] do
that do you if you could step into that
ring or that ugly orange orangutan
coming at you with the [ __ ] hard-on
if you can handle that [ __ ] oh I'm a
painter let's all cry for the painters
go [ __ ] yourself and your stupid van it
doesn't take a genius to figure out that
there's people out there will calling
themselves painters and they do just as
bad as Jerry read that and sure it's not
rocket science to apply a coat of paint
but paint selection is often overlooked
by amateurs see this is what I like the
of it it's one thing to slap some blue
paint on your dirty looking white walls
okay here's here's an argument on his
side how do I know that the paint isn't
from the last person that rented the
apartment what it really is is it's
probably from the cheap landlord that's
what it is
then I got dammit he's gonna [ __ ]
convince me that I'm wrong I'm not wrong
about you talking about my money you
[ __ ] [ __ ] but maybe I deserve that
because I went after your trade I don't
know yeah you're probably [ __ ] right
all right you're right all right it's
one thing to slap some blue paint paint
selection but it's one thing to slap
some blue paint on your dirty looking
white wall it's something else too first
carefully clean and patch the wall tape
off sections for protection apply a good
coat of water-based paint primer nobody
does that
then proudly take control of your roller
proudly and your container of glossy
aquamarine oil paint and turn the room
into something into someone's happy
place
I work quick effectively and take pride
in my work I really piss this guy up
people often can't thank me enough for
the job that I do oh [ __ ] I was with you
till then so keep on paying some bum
eight bucks an hour to paint your wall I
hope the reason why it looks like [ __ ]
will eventually penetrate your head
stupid red head keep doing what you do
with love and disrespect all right
you're right you're right listen to what
he said there I think what it is is is
so much of my life I rented and you know
landlords are notoriously cheap so they
probably just hired a bunch of [ __ ]
college kids people move out they fix
the wood and then they just slap white
paint you know why you know what you're
right you're right and then I bought the
house and my house was a hundred years
old and a bunch of tight [ __ ] or
do-it-yourselfers probably painted it
and I blamed your trade you know what
Touche sir you're absolutely right but
you know what god bless you for writing
that [ __ ] email because it was funny
as hell and it also took up a good ten
minutes of the podcast there all right
all right I'm done [ __ ] on painters
he's right but you know what I needed to
do it to learn something